good morning hickets tuesday this is a
story about spacewalking cosmonauts and
why we make art i often think about this
passage from you are an artist about
this 1515 etching of a rhinoceros by the
artist albrecht durer in which he
depicts the animal as having literal
plates of armor complete with rivets
durr had never actually seen a
rhinoceros he'd only read a description
and seen a small sketch and the fact
that his etching looks anything like a
rhino is a real testament to his genius
but in the places where durr's
rhinoceros is different from an actual
one
something else is betrayed about the
human imagination
which is that we tend to fill in blank
spaces or unknowns
with guesses that are deeply shaped by
our humanness when durer read that
rhinos had skin-like armor he imagined
16th century european human armor
because what else could he imagine sort
of by definition it is hard to think
about what we cannot imagine
but perhaps art is one way to bridge
that divide
and thinking about that makes me think
about the first work of art made by a
human in space the international space
station orbits earth every 90 minutes
and with each of these orbits the sun
rises from behind the earth
darkness giving way to an arc of blue
light that soon gives way to more colors
to hear space visitors talk of these
orbital sunrises
is to glimpse how amazing they must be
the american astronaut victor glover
wrote of the bands of color
they remind me of the scripture in psalm
weeping may endure for a night
but joy cometh in the morning
many space travelers have written of
experiencing so-called orbital
perspective
seeing the whole profoundly
interconnected planet from afar
teeming with life
vast and resilient
and fragile and tiny
astronaut mae jemison said that in space
i feel more expansive very connected to
the universe
the russian cosmonaut alexei leonov
wrote that looking back at our blue
globe from such a distance
profoundly changed my vision of space
and time
leonov is most remembered today for
taking the first space walk but he also
made the first space art in march of
1965 when he was 30 years old leonov
visited space with his friend and
colleague pasha belyayev the two men
orbited the earth in a tiny spherical
spacecraft that was just over two meters
in diameter and so they were only
allowed a few personal belongings on the
trip
leonov chose to bring a drawing pad and
some colored pencils
he'd loved making art since childhood he
wanted to go to art school but it was
too expensive so he became a pilot their
mission was known as voskod ii voskod
means sunrise in russian and despite
lasting for just over one day this space
flight contained quite a lot of firsts
not just the first spacewalk and the
first art made in space but also the
first spacecraft landing to occur 1500
miles off course after its occupants
nearly died on several separate
occasions the mission started out as
planned shortly after entering orbit
leonov wearing a spacesuit exited the
voskod capsule via an airlock and
floated in space connected to the
spaceship only by a tether the event was
broadcast live on soviet radio and
television and whenever my palms feel in
need of a bit of sweat i watch as leonov
pushes away from the spacecraft drifting
into the void
until his tether snaps taut after a few
minutes of spacewalking it was time for
leonov to re-enter the spaceship
but there was a problem his pressurized
suit had dramatically expanded in the
vacuum of space in his memoirs leonov
recalled my feet had pulled away from my
boots and my fingers from my gloves
attached to the sleeves making it
impossible to enter the airlock the only
solution was to reduce the pressure in
my suit by opening the pressure valve
and letting out a little oxygen at a
time as i tried to inch inside the
airlock and so as his oxygen leached out
into the void leonov tried to wedge
himself back into the capsule which he
described as an almost impossible
maneuver
this was not broadcast live on
television from the moment our mission
looked to be in jeopardy leonov wrote
transmissions from our spacecraft were
suddenly suspended without explanation
in their place mozart's requiem was
played again and again on state radio
the custom in the soviet union at this
time was for such solemn music to play
after a senior political figure had died
but before an official announcement of
their death was made
leonov's friends and family who of
course knew what the music might mean
waited for the news with no way of
knowing what was happening miles above
as his suit shrank and his oxygen
dwindled leonov eventually managed to
get back inside the capsule
he was drenched with sweat breathless
and overwhelmed with adrenaline
his compatriot calmed him down saying
that they had 90 minutes before they
needed to eject the airlock
maybe alexei could use that time to rest
or to write up a report of the spacewalk
but leonov found that he could neither
sleep nor write
instead to calm himself and to capture
the moment he took those minutes to make
some art i reached for my sketch pad and
colored pencils and sat quietly drawing
my first impressions of the panorama i
had seen while floating free in space
i tried to capture the different shades
of charcoal rings that make up the
earth's atmosphere
the sunrise or air glow over the earth's
horizon
the blue belt covering the earth's crust
and the spectrum of colors i had
observed looking down at the globe the
sketch is simple it was made quickly in
a weightless environment with simple
drawing instruments
but it is also stunningly beautiful it
says something to me that the first art
made by humans from outside of earth's
atmosphere
depicts earth's atmosphere
leonov was astonished by the brightness
of stars from space
but he did not draw that
nor did he draw himself floating looking
up at the spaceship
he drew
home
he drew what mary oliver memorably
called
this
the one world we all belong to
i will never see an orbital sunrise in
real life on many levels i'm not cut out
for space travel an inner ear disorder
has damaged my sense of balance for
starters
but also i'm not a pilot or an engineer
or a billionaire
i tend to side with eudora welty on
matters of adventure
who once after acknowledging she had
lived a sheltered wife added
a sheltered life can be a daring life as
well
for all serious daring starts from
within
my daring also generally ends within and
so i will only ever have descriptions
and depictions of space
like albrecht durer and his rhinoceros
when it comes to orbital sunrises i am
wholly dependent upon words and images
made by other people
and that is one gift of art it can be a
window albeit not a fully transparent
one
into other worlds
and other lives after making his sketch
of the orbital sunrise leonov returned
to the business of space travel he and
belyayov ejected the airlock which led
to an unexpected and uncontrolled spin
of the aircraft there was no longer the
pleasure of a sunrise every 90 minutes
now their spacecraft was spinning wildly
with the sunlight streaming in through
the window creating a strobe light
effect
on the ground mozart's requiem played
over and over on the radio
while in space the emergencies
multiplied the automatic guidance system
of their craft failed so the cosmonauts
would have to manually choose a landing
site
leonov couldn't navigate toward the
original site so after extensive
calculations made while wildly spinning
in space he chose a site 1500 miles to
the west
in a vast wilderness
that way if they crashed they at least
wouldn't kill anyone on the ground
they landed in a forest in two feet of
snow
with their escape hatch blocked by a
tree that had fallen as the spacecraft
barreled into it
it took the two cosmonauts hours of
rocking the capsule back and forth from
within
to free the escape hatch
and then they spent a very long
and very cold night in the siberian
wilderness before rescuers arrived the
next day
at last the two men skied nine
kilometers with a rescue party to a site
where a helicopter could land
and that is how the cosmonauts of
voscode2 survived
and with them the first picture of an
orbital sunrise
i like to look at leonov's drawing when
i am feeling exhausted by despair and
drudgery
or when i feel the weight of longing and
fear pressing in on my chest
i look at the picture and i think of all
that had to happen
for the drawing to exist
for lanov to exist
for anything to exist
for me
art is a kind of landing site in the
wilderness
art is where i go
when i do not know where else to go
through art paradoxes of consciousness
resolve for me
i see what i will never see
i know
what i will never know
and i survive
what i will not survive
i will never see an orbital sunrise
but thanks to alexei leonov
i can still feel the wonder and
consolation of it
hank
i'll see you on friday